All right, so here's a summary of
what we're just talking about.
We have, actually have these two
different forms of the bellman equation.
One V which we can think
of as standing for value.
And one Q which we can think
of as standing for quality.
But mostly they're just letters from
the end of the alphabet that we
made up names for.
So you had U for utility.
This is V for value and Q for quality.
But anyway, the point is that
these are just expressions,
that represent different pieces of
this overall sequence of states and
rewards and actions.
>> Okay, so I got two questions.
One is, why?
I mean, why are we bothering to
create this quality function,
when the value function worked
just fine, thank you very much?
Well, I'll ask the second question
after you give me a satisfactory
answer to the first one.
>> So why?
So, in some sense because
they're both equally good.
But in fact what's going to
turn out to be the case,
is that this Q form of
the Bellman equation.
Is going to be much more useful in
the context of reinforcement learning.
And the reason for
that is we're going to be able to take
expectations of this quantity
using just experienced data.
And you don't need to actually to have
direct access to the reward function or
the transition function.
To do that.
Whereas if we're going to
try to learn V values.
The only way to connect one
V value to the next V value
is by knowing the transitions and
rewards.
So this is going to be really helpful in
the context of reinforcement learning.
Where we don't know the transitions and
rewards in advance.
>> Okay, I'll buy that.
So here's my second question then.
You've got V function for
what happens when you're at a state.
You've got a Q function would
happen when you're at an action.
There's at least one more thing
when you're at that infinite
jar jar jar jar jar, and that's R.
>> Yes.
You're saying we can group things this
way, or we can group things this way.
So why can't we group things this way?
>> Sure, that's what I'm asking.
>> because if we go one step more
than that then we're back to
the max again and that was our V.
>> Right.
>> So yeah, that seems to be the third
member of our little trio that's
been left out.
So I think maybe we should
have a quiz about that.
>> Of course we should.